[Music]
and no homeowners no no homo submitted
by soon double to do soon the boo crew
soft tofu soup in Koreans have that
Korean hot soup cinema of course a man
was cleared of murder using the gay
panic defense gay panic what is that and
he was clear can you teach me so he's
like a gay guy anyway the wrist flicks
right am I gonna get off made guessing
cuz he's like okay that type of geek
panic yep oh I ain't gay I'm gay I don't
know does that mean you what squeeze
your bubble tight know what is that the
new squeeze your butthole
it's gay defense isn't it oh I see I
don't talk I ain't gay and then you go
yeah don't attack me there whew call
that the gay guard was a fighter but
yeah nobody so stories about James and
David James 69 years old David was 32 so
if it's dead yeah
so James apparently retired from the
Austin Police Department
he took up guitar and he started playing
his instrument nearby musicians bar I'm
done shooting people he was he was
trying to put together a jazz band and
so you tired from the police now it's a
jazz scooby-doo you do don't you and so
through that he met David pow pow
that's your scat
Geo how dare you
it's a policeman that became a jack
purging your incursion what did i do
suppose you just said everything I'm
gonna kick it
there's nothing against am i [ __ ]
scatter it's so stupid
alright so James and David were
neighbors so James was trying to put
together a band and David's house right
so like Hugh and David was a saxophonist
and so they were good as a sex offender
dave was a sex offender some minor
detail whatever there's nothing to do
with it back to the musical instrument
he's playing so it's a guitar corny ass
like eighties music video where he heard
something clink and then that he started
making music like the cuffs out what's
that always finds a ratcheting noise but
they're never anywhere yes he it's not
ratchety you can never find rachie
noises anywhere it's like there's music
everywhere how Danny did that's good
[Laughter]
that's yes an all right so yeah they
ended up becoming friends and then
there's one night after a night of music
and drinking at David's place the
younger guys right yeah younger 32 uh
let's play bass and I'll [ __ ] do
baritone on a ballsack Oh what's this
new sound
apparently you gonna like trash it
playing with the balls right here and
he's like hey let me try something else
dude he's like wait when you get deep
like that it creates a really cool
rhythm you're all jamming up the skin
flute yeah so James says that they were
playing back and forth and everything
and that he let him know hey I'm not gay
jammin out oh hey how about we just
[ __ ] kiss like the greenness do sad
music hey by the way real quick
there are not a [ __ ] Manitoba it with the
old guys all the young guys again yes in
that context man and apparently the
younger dude goes in for a kiss and
that's when the older dude pulls out a
knife and started stabbing him twice so
says the only surviving witness by the
way yeah why the younger guy went to
kiss the old ass dude sure so then
that's when James went to the police
department a few hours later at around
3:45 a.m. and he he told the police I
think I killed someone I stabbed him he
was charged with murder
three years later James claims that the
killing was in self-defense and that he
was in a gay panic after being hit on by
another man and so this turned out to be
a legitimate defense because he got off
of murder wait wait wait wait since when
you feel like a gay guys hitting on you
and then you attack contact them no this
[ __ ] I think is what really happened he
wouldn't give him no booty hall so he
stabbed him yep what's actually wanna
[ __ ] know what's actually crazy is that
that's a viable defense in all but two
states yeah for Han Illinois [ __ ]
that is insane I know me the other way
around it's because like all these like
homophobic people in charge like we're
like yeah that's sounds pretty legit I
do them a guy gig I come to you
defending yourself case dismissed
yeah I wanna kill that guy if that if
that gay try to kiss me imma murder him
horrible so this is James and this was
David I don't I don't believe it
no I don't believe that the 30 year old
was hitting on that grandpa because even
in straight relationships right why
would I want to [ __ ] [ __ ] like old
prune [ __ ] old [ __ ] bag of raisins
what I [ __ ] that no or it could be like
ah James knew that David was gay he
doesn't have no age I think that's
exactly what brandy worked off work for
years that's what's really good is that
this law even exists or that or that not
law but that this defense exists I think
that's like one of those things we're
like straight people think you know if
someone's gay then automatically they
want to get they're gonna very
resistible to each other whatever but in
this case it doesn't seem right just a
30 year old hitting on a [ __ ] grandpa
yeah he's not even attractive grandpa
right and it's like yeah this is the
[ __ ] where I'm like dude we got more
work to do man this is this is not right
that is not a viable defense give me
everything I need to put on my Sherlock
Holmes glanced on and [ __ ] figured
his mouthful girl Susan what happened
with James at the end so the jurors did
not find him guilty of murder or
manslaughter he was convicted of
criminally negligent homicide
he will not spend a day in prison he was
sentenced to six months in jail and he
will have to complete 100 hours of
community service pay $11,000 in
restitution to David's family justice
systems to work and use a portable
alcohol monitoring service for at least
a year what the probation for a decade
well how the poor guy how do i how do I
get on was that Thomas I'd word what is
that word [ __ ] irresponsible homicide
criminally negligent homicide I want to
do that and not do any [ __ ] jail time
yeah negligent homicide sucks
that's crazy man kiss me mmm how do you
even prove that like that's that's
ridiculous they just had to seduce the
court I think he came on to the guy and
then the guy rejected him and he [ __ ]
wondered that that's what he put himself
out there and being gay is like
something that he thinks is terrible her
like a terrible admission and so then
he's gotten like
thinking through in there was the fact
that James is five four which is eight
inches shorter than David and so he
testified that he felt threatened by
being in David's home and so that's what
he attacked him all right dude I don't
[ __ ] get that [ __ ] and I love that
all the juries were like that's very
reasonable
hood it's not that I don't know I just
know that Austin has awesome barbecue
and a cool part of town called sixth
Street where people get drunk and you
can watch them and horses are like
running into them because the cops ride
horses there it's pretty awesome
that's like nylons mm-hmm violence is
like that mm-hmm I remember um when I
was dating does she lived out there and
then it was like during the time when
the whole gay stuff was cooked like like
I don't know because I'm some kind of
gay political stuff was going on right
maybe the marriage maybe maybe but then
like when we went out so many gay people
were like we're not gonna hide anymore
and everybody was walking around holding
hands and being gay and [ __ ] and then I
was like yeah that's awesome
yeah but then but it was different cause
out here it's kind of like man it's just
everyday I'm a [ __ ] yeah I'ma be gay
right but over there it was like it's
art day today is the day that we could
hold hands in public and not hide
anymore
I like that Joe goes up to two gay guys
and he's like I just think it's awesome
you guys are being gained [ __ ] that's
what I felt about oh boy I was like you
so gay be gay that's cool man it's times
that that's the that's like we're doing
a Saturday morning special like a very
special episode right you gotta do one
of those that's cool oh man
see you later you don't have to hide no
more but yes oh the American Bar
Association is urging lawmakers across
the u.s. to curtail the availability and
effectiveness of the gay panic and trans
panic defense because it's just
revitalizing a person who's been
attacked just because of their sexuality
yeah so we'll see what happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]